- No one is ever perfect,
and just remember
that progress is better than perfection.
- I'm so excited that
you are gonna be doing
this Zero-waste challenge with me.
Are you down to show me your
trash from a regular day?
- I bought some seaweed
snacks, sparkling water,
root beer, and I ate this yesterday.
This is all of my waste.
- So, since you hardly make any trash
and your already really low waste
maybe this can more be a tutorial
and just showing people
how you avoid waste.
- We need can do that.
- I'm excited for you to show us
how we can reduce waste
and be more low waste.
- Hi everybody, it's Leah Thomas
and I'm gonna be showing you all
how I reduce waste and telling you
all about the waste that I do get.
So here is my kind of
like Mason jar collection
its absolutely made my life a lot easier
and that's just so easy to always have
like containers to put stuff in.
It's really what helps me not
really have a ton of waste.
So what are some other things
in my house that I can show you?
I like to package a lot of my
food in these sorts of bags.
This is a way that I also
stay low waste at my house.
They come in all different
shapes and sizes.
If I don't want to use plastic
when I'm out and about,
I have things like this
they have wooden forks and
knives and put cutlery.
I try to be like super
free giving on myself.
Like for example, I really
wanted some bagels, right?
So I have this bagel
and it comes in plastic
and I don't know, I need to eat.
So when I really want bagels,
and these happened to be the ones
that were sold at Trader Joe's.
- So we actually met when we did a video
where you were explaining the intersection
between environmentaLism
and black lives matter.
And since then, I know
you have started this
awesome thing called
intersectional environmentalist.
Could you tell me a little
bit more about that?
- Intersectional environmentalist
is an online platform that started
during the summer of 2020.
That's all about
exploring the relationship
between social justice
and environmentalism
because there are so many
links and interconnections.
They're really trying
to make environmental
education accessible to everyone.
This is like a daily vitamin that I use
and it comes in packaging that is
compostable and biodegradable.
And I just pour these refills into
my glass container, so that way
I don't have to go to
the store and you know,
buy a bunch of plastic
and things like that,
even things like, you know, cotton swabs,
just making sure that
I'm getting some sort
of like easily recyclable packaging
because the majority of consumer waste
actually comes from packaging
and that's pretty messed up.
I'm primarily plant-based
and I just really
need certain vitamins,
but I like to prioritize
like glass containers because
those are really easily recyclable
- In the past, I've defined zero waste
as trying to send as little
as possible to landfill.
I'm wondering how you
would define zero waste.
- So I've been gravitating towards the
terminology, low waste versus zero waste.
In reality, it's just saying, okay,
if you have plastic,
making sure you're able
to recycle it, doing as much as you can
to divert any waste away from a landfill.
To my surprise, I almost
felt like I kind of
passed a test when I was talking
to Aurin because currently, I'm one of
the more low waste people
that she's talked to.
Even as an environmental blogger,
I get sent lots of things, so the majority
of my waste is honestly
from packaging or from food.
Just so you get a little sneak peek.
Here are some of my packages that I get.
Thankfully, a lot of it does
come in recycled packaging.
I also donate a lot of those things
to people who need it, I also gift my mom
with a lot of things or like my employees
or my coworkers and stuff like that.
- How do you think this zero
waste movement can grow?
- Zero waste, like we
were talking about before
it's been almost positioned as something
that only wealthy folks can do
and you can't buy your
way into sustainability.
I don't really see a lot of representation
of people of color or
people like my grandma.
There are a lot of people who are living
low waste out of necessity.
It's actually kind of
funny how consumerism has
infiltrated the zero waste circle.
And that's really not what it's about.
So I think that's kind of been a shift
that I'm seeing while
am, you know, kind of
transitioning more so
towards you know, low waste
- The truth is zero waste is low waste.
You can never be zero
waste, it's just like
striving to do that, and it's funny too
because the most zero waste thing
is to not buy anything but then now
there's this whole like
industry of products
that have been built around supporting
the zero waste lifestyle, which is
I think sort of inherently not zero waste.
- I like to use laundry detergent
that doesn't really require a ton of waste
whether it's things that
aren't using plastic.
So something like this, it's from Dropps
and it comes in like a cardboard box
which is really easy to
recycle it's unscented.
So it's not using any
like toxic waste and dyes.
I feel like this is kind of fun
as an environmentalist sometimes, honestly
like I always feel like
I'm not doing enough.
And sometimes I feel
ashamed about the trash
that I do have but I
guess it's really nice
and important to remind yourself
of the things that you are doing.
So that's a little bit
about how I try to reduce
my waste around the house
I recycle when I can.
And I try to make sure the packaging
that I'm buying always has some sort of
strategy for its end of life.
And also not shaming
myself if I'm not perfect
cause we're in a Panorama right now.
So it's totally okay.
- You're already really far along
on your low waste journey and
being an environmentalist.
What would you say to people
who are starting on their journey?
- You know, you can't buy
your way into sustainability.
I don't want to confuse anyone to think
that you have to like
be this mega consumer
in order to be zero
waste because honestly,
a lot of people probably
have all the tools
and solutions already at home.
- For people who have never heard the term
intersectional environmentalism.
Can you explain what that is?
- Intersectional environmentalism
in essence just means taking an approach
to environmentalism that
also evaluates, you know,
class, race, gender, sexuality, etcetera,
and also accessibility.
- And how do we find out more
about intersectional environmentalist?
- You can check out our website
@intersectionalenvironmentalist.com.
Also our Instagram
@intersectionalenvironmentalist.
(upbeat music)